hello and welcome to the 29 PHP tutorial
as tutorial we discuss how to pull
elements from our table in our database
and this tutorial we're going to discuss
how to insert things into a table in a
database so with that let's go ahead and
hop right on in at the moment our
database contains two elements that
would be Harrison named Harrison age 99
named Jackie age 55 so now let's insert
a few more elements into this database
so to do that just like before because
we specify some sort but what we want
the query to contain so we'll do SQL
again and this query this time we'll do
insert in two and then again with a
Tildy you give the table name in our
case it's epic table and then you
specify the values that you want to put
into the table so let's just enter some
data in here let's say we're going to
enter John and we're going to say John
is 88 now it's a it's a yeah Thunder 88
now what we're going to do next is due
and an if statement so we're going to
say if and then set up our structure if
at query or at sorry at dulles on query
so we're calling this query equals and
we'll put the outside in there just
sounds the earth we get it equals my SQL
underscore query and within here we put
that query this SQL here so number SQL
is the query earth number dollar sign
SQL is the one we want to call if we do
that then we just want to go ahead and
echo out success and then just in case
will create an
eles and if we don't succeed we're going
to go ahead and echo fail to insert and
after all this we're going to go ahead
and call a close to the connection so
with that will save it and put it up pop
over here refresh and you see we got a
success so let's go to our database
again let's load up the epic table
browse and sure enough there's John with
an age of 88 so let's say now we want to
sense since this column of data is an
integer that's why we put it in its
integer but now let's say we want to cuz
you don't wanna have to hard code this
you know that's not very practical as
time goes on you're not going to do that
you're going to want to stick variables
in here so how do we do that so now what
we're going to want to do is let's just
make a few a couple of variables real
quick so we'll say name equals and here
we'll say bat that and then age is going
to equal um will say Beth is up sorry
around the proposed Beth is 22 so now
our SQL query every time we call the
query like say we're you know
dynamically generating name and age like
say we have some sort of form and we
want to insert name and age into
database now we want to insert that as a
variable so how do we do that what we're
going to do is inside the quotes and
they are going to be single quotes
within a query now normally to put the
like we were talking about earlier you'd
have to use double quotes to put in a
variable but when we do that it's not
working because it's cancelling out our
already double quoted statement so
instead you actually just use a single
quote and you can see it bolds it just
like it would if it in the other
scenario so first we want to insert name
and then we want to insert age and it
has to be in the order like the correct
order like over here you can see the
first column is named the second column
is age so you want to make it the same
order if you do have a table like a lot
of tables will have a
incrementing key for ID if you do have
that you would have three values like
this and you would just leave this blank
and the sense it's a self or what's
called auto increment it will
automatically fill that one so you don't
you don't really want to insert it into
anything there but in our case we just
have these two columns so that's what
we're going to do and then everything
else stays the same if this query works
at a lack of a success if not it'll say
failed the insert and then when it's
done it's going to go ahead and close so
let's say that and see how that works
out refresh and again we see success
let's pop back over to our table and
there we have John and then we've got
Beth at 22 so that's it with inserting
into a database via SQL i will add
however if you plan to use this maybe
with like some sort of forms and submits
and all this kind of stuff i highly
suggest you look up proper security
procedures for doing this as there's all
sorts of little crafty and manipulative
things people can do using what's called
SQL injection so do be careful make sure
you do your research and you understand
what you're doing before you do it
especially if you are starting to like
harbor people's personal information
like username passwords or credit card
information and so on you probably
should learn about SQL injection and how
to protect against various things
another good idea is to silence SQL
errors like we do here with this act
query so if you get an error it's not
shown to everybody the paths that you're
using so anyway just be careful and as
always thank you for watching